yeah very quick
just a little bit about me and my
background I did my graduate work in
economics I'm trained as an applied
econometrics in I created the stats
models package in Python I spent a lot
of time working on that instead of my
graduate school and so here I am now at
a PI data conference instead of
somewhere else I now work at civis
analytics I run our R&D department and I
am a product lead civis is a data
science services and technology company
we help businesses make better decisions
with data science and technology we
started out of the Obama campaign in
2013 and have been chugging along since
then based out of Chicago yeah so the
idea for this talk had been rattling
around in my head for about a year or so
but the genesis for actually sitting
down and riding the talk was this tweet
so credit where credit is due this is
cam davidson Pilon he's the director of
data at Shopify wrote a book bayesian
methods for hackers and he has this
quote he said I'm predicting an
econometrics UBB revolution in data
science followed by a credibility crisis
followed by a retreat to experimental
design which I agree with the premise of
not necessarily the conclusion but it it
helps kind of solidify what I wanted to
talk about today and we're gonna focus a
little bit about what does it mean to
have an econometrics up revolution what
does this even mean why is there a
credibility crisis I'll argue that there
is it's not just kind of looming and
coming but we have one and we live in
one and then you know what should we
learn what should we take away and what
should we do about it focusing on the
kind of the science of data science so
just to set the scene a little bit we're
going to go through four decades of
econometrics history and we're gonna do
it in about two minutes
so in 1983 ed lima wrote this kind of
manifesto called let's take the con out
of econometrics back then you know
empirical economics didn't have an
impact on policy making decision makers
didn't really take it seriously a lot of
the studies were you know based on
twenty to twenty five data points and it
was all kind of Theory driven whoever
was kind of a loudest had to say on what
policy decisions were made but fast
forward about three or four decades in
2010 to apply to condom attrition Zanger
esteem Pischke wrote this paper called
the credibility revolution in empirical
economics how better research design is
taking the con out of econometrics so
what does that mean they argued
basically that you know because of the
strides that had been taken in the field
that now econometrics and economics
mattered people listen to what
economists had to say and making policy
decisions so why was there a problem
before the at the time of lemur a lot of
the arguments that were taking place in
their literature you know the paper
rejoinder rejoinder rejoinder rejoinder
we're arguing about whether or not they
logged a variable or what the functional
form of the equation was that they were
trying to estimate so it's no wonder
that no one wasn't really paying
attention or thinking that the the
conclusions they were coming to were
valid so what happened in the interim
one more and better data so this is kind
of a no-brainer there's fewer
distractions and this was led by better
econometrics theory so people stopped
talking about functional form they
realized that you know with some study
and some better understanding of what we
were actually doing it didn't actually
if you were careful it didn't really
actually matter if you logged a variable
or not or if you picked the wrong a
functional form under certain conditions
you could still make valid conclusions
from data and then there's just better
research design overall this is the crux
of their argument this is what we're
going to talk about today and but what a
better research design mean it meant one
the rise of quasi experimental designs
so you know we kind of know that the
randomized control trial is the the gold
standard for making decisions or
conclusions using the scientific method
it's really hard to do in economics and
as we'll see also in businesses so
methods to help people do what we call
quasi experimental design and we'll dig
into what that means a little bit and
then some subfields actually started
doing randomized control trials and so
this was great the conclusions people
were making were well understood
and believable the the kind of
counterclaim which is I would argue a
good problem to have is basically okay
we now know that you know you're doing
these studies and what you're saying is
true but does it generalize which is
which is a good problem to have a good
question to be asking so the outcome was
basically that economists now had
relevance of Holly's policy decisions
people listen to them that's great and
why so this is the subtle but key part
of their argument it's this focus on
research design and good design lends
itself to basically better communication
so good good designs are simple and they
lead to a straightforward presentation
of results and we'll see exactly what
this means and this is kind of a common
theme and a lot of the talks that I've
been given recently like one of the
biggest problems in all of data sciences
of people don't know how to talk to each
other so if there's one kind of takeaway
that you take from this talk it's that
simple effective communication can take
you further in your career and have make
you have a larger impact than just about
anything else
so okay I've hinted at a little bit what
does this actually have to do with with
a data science so first I heard some
people talking beforehand about what is
actually data science I'm just gonna put
up a definition and say it's true it
will be true for this talk so this is a
little bit some of the evolution of some
terminology that people have used or
some method definitions of people have
used to talk about data science I will
just say a data scientist uses
multidisciplinary methods to understand
and have a measurable impact on a
business process or product and this
measurable impact is actually really
really key so it doesn't mean you go out
and do a bunch of cool stuff and it
never matters it's actually following
through and having the impact that's one
of the most important parts and so how
do they do this
ideally but rarely they follow basically
the scientific method so this is not
anything terribly new probably to most
people in this room it looks a little
bit different within an organization but
the first step is you come up with a
question it's a product or business
question either comes from you
comes from the business so a couple of
examples how do our marketing campaigns
perform what's driving employee
attrition so these are just questions
next we come up with a hypothesis it
necessarily has to be falsifiable so it
has to be something that we can say is
true or we're not sure or Icefall so
we're not sure so for example the return
on investment for our marketing
campaigns is greater than break even so
it either is or it isn't so we now have
something that we want to measure and
now comes the the kind of interesting
part what we're going to talk about
today is research design you need to sit
down and design a strategy that allows
you to test this hypothesis and takes
into account you know the threats the
validity so how can my approach fail
basically and then the analysis step is
a whole lot of trying to see if you're
wrong
trying to it like test your threats to
validity and then finally you need to
communicate the results in a way that
people understand whether that's
business stakeholders whether it's
engineering team anyone in your
organization if you don't do the last
final step then it doesn't matter so we
work a lot with you know large
organizations across the country like
fortune 50 companies and we've had you
know executives that these large
organizations sit down with our CEO and
say I have a team of 150 data scientists
I have no idea what they do they have no
measurable impact on how I make
decisions that is bad and what we're
gonna do is talk about some methods that
I hope can push us towards having a more
credibility so where does this
credibility crisis come from which parts
of these steps are we failing at I argue
it's these three so the question is
basically everyone's responsibility but
they're often unclear and success is
left undefined so some of you may have
worked on teams or have friends that
work on teams that are very much an
example of this they go to work and
they're unclear of what they need to be
doing the business stakeholders are
unclear about what they can be doing
what they should even expect from them
and it leads to kind of chaos and no
impact a focus on research design so a
lot of data science in the last decade
five to ten years has been focused on a
black box predictive model
so this isn't totally fair and I'll talk
about why it's not but a lot of the
hotness is I go into a computer science
program and I focus on machine learning
I focus on deep learning which is great
and they're like a valid use cases for
that but it's it's not everything
especially if you need to then turn
around and have an impact and have
credibility these threats to validity of
understanding what we're trying to
measure are just brushed aside or not
even thought about because they're
people are not necessarily all trained
and how to think like this and then
finally is this communication theme back
again people don't know how to talk to
each other or don't necessarily even
understand the value of what's been done
so ok am I saying the data scientist is
just about running experiments kind of
it kind of is so back to a good design
simple explanation this it doesn't get
simpler than this in terms of kind of
the scientific method randomized control
trials the gold standard of what we're
trying to do so we have a population
that we want to understand and then we
have a treatment effect that we want to
measure say in this case it's you know
we want to have a job training program
that we think will increase productivity
of our workers we're a company that has
offices warehouses distribution centers
and we want to better train our workers
so they're more productive so we
randomly assign all the workers to a job
training program the only difference
between them then is that they either
got the program or they didn't and then
we measure was productivity higher and
here we see the treated group and the
control group we may start to think ok
yeah it looks like this job productivity
or job training program led to higher
productivity in this case again because
the only difference between these two
groups because of random assignment is
the job training it unfortunately never
really works like this in the real world
especially within organizations it's a
hard sell and here's a few reasons of
why it's a hard sell these are all as
close to quotes as my memory will allow
of actual discussions that we've had
with organ
patience so say one of the things you
want to do is have better sales have a
better targeting program for your
salespeople reach out to people they
know they're going to be able to have an
impact with well you pitch this to the
VP of Sales and the VP of Sales says
well you got a program to make people
better at selling everybody's getting
that we're not gonna not give that to
some people just so we can see whether
or not it has an effect and so ok so I
think the quote was like that's taking
food out of my mouth I'm not gonna opt
in to the B group mm-hmm so if you want
to measure digital ad effectiveness
running a control ad is too expensive so
you go to a CMO and you tell her ok your
marketing budget is you know 80 million
dollars I just need a million of that to
run a control ad which is going to be a
public service announcement so that we
can see if you're real I had had an
effect and she looks at you like you're
crazy there's no way I'm spending a
million dollars to buy a PSA that's not
what we're in the business of if we have
an ad we're gonna run ok I hope it works
and then if you want to do some
interventions for customer retention so
it's it's kind of the results will be
difficult to interpret we're never
actually going to know whether the
campaign or what we're trying to
undertake I had an effect so let's just
not try ok so and even if we could run
an experiment things can go wrong with
experiments so you may have insufficient
randomization so in the job training
example you may have randomized at the
county level and what you end up
measuring is actually like the education
in certain counties like maybe people
did come out of certain counties are
just better trained so your experimental
design is invalid you did not measure a
job training program spillover effects
you do the job training program some
people see it their leaders and
organizations and some people are not
getting a job training they think it's
great
so they post all the materials and some
people go out and try to do it
themselves
your experiment is now invalid you can't
measure the effects to the job training
program and then partial compliance and
attrition the more human factors so some
people may show up to the job training
but they don't pay attention they just
sleep in the back or attrition they only
took sign up at the first one so they
assumed everybody went through the whole
training program
and they didn't so these are all threats
threats to the validity of a randomized
control trial so all is not lost but
this is actually where the social
science comes in handy so I think the
the science behind data scientists stea
science looks a lot more like the social
sciences then we may have acknowledged
in the past and I'm not just trying to
justify going to grad school and I'm
pretty sure that's true but we'll see
you tell me so we didn't run an
experiment we had a job training program
and we let people self-select into it
and we know we didn't run a randomized
control trial but hey that's why we
learned regression in undergrad right we
just need to run a regression and
everything's fine so d here is whether
or not you are in the job training
program and then X is everything else
you know about each individual so you
weren't randomly assigned to that job
training program but if we control for
everything then what we're left with is
the partial correlation of the job
training program on Y productivity great
let's just do that
so what can go wrong if we do that so
G's are just a few threats to validity
and a regression approach the first is
omitted variable bias so did we omit
variables that could plausibly explain
the outcome of interest so people may
actually be going out and doing training
on their own they may be going to night
school and you didn't measure that you
didn't know that and so the thing that
you're capturing is actually the fact
that these people are getting training
somewhere else
so your your experiment is invalid in
dodging ad bias so this is kind of the
what's the direction of causation so
maybe you're a consultant or maybe you
work in kind of a center of excellence
model doing data science for an
organization they come to you and
they're like hey we want to do this X
post and measure whether or not this job
training program had an effect the
problem is the person whose project this
was isn't there anymore and what they
did was actually target all the low
productivity facilities for this job
training in the first place but
everybody forgot that it's like lost to
institutional knowledge your experiment
is invalid
finally there's sample selection bias so
maybe you actually did ask people to
sign up and only the people that opted
in did the job training and those people
were like just go Gators
so they're different and so you're not
actually measuring the effect of the job
training you're you're figuring out that
your go Gators are more productive
so all of these bias this coefficient D
so you measure it you estimate it it's
wrong so what can we do to avoid some of
these threats to validity just some
research design strategies from the
social sciences because this is the
bread and butter of economics of
political science it's really hard to
run experiments in an in industry as
well as in these academic settings so
we've spent you know the better part of
a century developing maybe more
developing methods to try to take care
of these things so the first method is
probably the most esoteric it's called
an instrumental variable regression this
is popularized by Steven Levitt in the
book Freakonomics
so if you've ever heard of that or read
that most of the design research design
strategies in that book are instrumental
variables which I also call just like
clever econometrics so what is it well
first of all I can get around problems
like reverse causation so maybe you want
to test the effect of a blood pressure
medication and so you would enroll
people in a study and then you say don't
change anything about your life here's
this blood pressure medication and then
you have a placebo and the actual pill
but then they start thinking a lot about
blood pressure and they also start going
to a gym and they get a personal trainer
you're no longer measuring the effect of
just that medication the other is common
unobserved confounders so this is
something like late a latent variable
like ability determines whether or not
you're more productive and whether you
go to the job training so it's actually
you know whether or not you're a
go-getter that matters but what you have
is now spurious correlation between the
job training and productivity but you
because you didn't measure the like
you're just a go-getter so what we do is
we find very
it's called instruments that are
correlated with X but not caused by Y
and that affect Y but only through X
I'll explain what this means so this is
a kind of a now classic example from the
economics literature in econometrics the
Fulton fish market paper so I think the
idea of this paper was they wanted to
understand how demand changes with they
like put in a tax policy for the price
of fish at the Fulton fish market in New
York so they wanted to basically
estimate the demand curve okay great
so I went to the fish market collected a
bunch of data for a bunch of different
days and then they regret regressed
quantity on price its downward sloping
that's a demand curve rock so if you
remember econ 101 each one of these data
points is an intersection of a supply
curve and the demand curve so we
actually don't know whether the prices
changed here because of or the
quantities here changed it's because of
either supply effects or demand effects
so the researcher who worked on this
paper she thought of a clever instrument
and that instrument was weather so the
weather off the in particular the
weather off the coast in New York so if
the weather was really bad not that many
fishermen went out to catch fish that
day so it artificially restricted the
quantity but the weather was really nice
in Manhattan so everybody was still
going to the fish market and buying
their fish for their restaurants or
whatever so what they did was estimate
they estimated effects that were just
dude as changes in supply and so weather
here is the instrument and now you've
isolated the demand effects and now you
can isolate the demand curve or estimate
the demand curve another common
technique is this is a whole series of
techniques actually there's a whole
literature behind this but called
matching so matching basically creates a
pseudo control group and based on your
treatment group so you ran a randomized
experiment or you ran an experiment but
it wasn't randomized what you need to do
is find a bunch of people that were not
exposed to your treatment but look a
heck of a lot like almost exactly like
the people who were exposed and in that
case what you've done is created a
pseudo control group and now you can
plausibly estimate the effect of your
treatment so this looks a lot like a
randomized control trial the trick is
here estimating this group such that
comparing these two groups is valid
basically and then you just match and
measure the difference and now you have
average treatment effect another
technique is called difference and
differences so you can use difference in
differences if you have two or more
groups and you measure them over time
and in between the two measurement
groups there's an intervention or
treatment so the example here is you
know maybe you're doing a cohort
analysis so you have two groups of
customers you have your loyal old
customers that are here at kind of the
yellow line and then you have new
customers so both they're trending up
over time because everybody loves your
stuff it's great and they're buying a
lot of it but in the interim you ran an
email campaign and you just reached out
to your loyal customers you reached out
the people who had purchased from you
more than ten times say so they started
at a higher baseline now if you were
naive and tried to measure the effect of
this then you may think the effect of
your loyalty campaign is this whole
difference but it's not it's actually
just the difference in differences right
so it's this smaller but now validly
measured effect so you see that a lot in
time series experiments next regression
discontinuity so if there is a technical
natural or randomly occurring cutoff
that decides whether or not you are
assigned to treatment then you can use
this what we call a regression
discontinuity to measure the effect of a
treatment so the crux here is that the
observations that are on either side of
that treatment line for all intents and
purposes look almost exactly alike so
you may use this a lot in like
targeted display advertising people who
didn't get an ad or did get an ad and a
machine is making that decision that's
what we call like a technical cutoff and
you can you can exploit that to try to
measure the effect of your campaign so
in this case let's think about our job
training example again so say HR rolls
out the job training policy and that's
great but they decided that every class
that's under 20 is now breakout sessions
so it's taught differently it's more
interactive so what you can do is the
colors don't show up here that well but
you can take the groups really close to
20 and on both sides and think these are
your treated groups so this is like
treat does the lecture format is it more
effective than a small group discussion
format and you kind of throw away
everybody else because you know they're
probably different the idea being that
the size of this two companies means
that they're probably alike and most of
the characteristics that you care about
so on this thing's the last kind of
technique that I'll talk about today I
could go on for a very long time but
it's serving experiments so survey
experiments are increasingly used
everywhere especially in political
science somewhere between a true
experiment and a quasi experiment you
basically give a survey instrument to a
bunch of randomly selected people and
you can test a whole host of hypotheses
that you care about we'll look at a
really cool example of this in a little
bit what are some of the different kinds
of survey experiments so this is just
randomly picked three so that you can
have scenario based surveys where you
want to test aspects of a hypothetical
scenario so if you work on a product
team with a product manager and the
product manager has five things that
they care about and there's 15 different
attributes they can change and each one
of those five things it's really hard to
know what to do so one of the ways you
can do this is design a survey
experiment which basically involves
asking some people some of the questions
and then try to figure out the best
thing overall to do so that's a cool a
cool technique priming and framing
survey experiments you could use this to
test creative or I don't know a like
political ad and see if it has an
don't people and whether or not they
then would show up to vote or change
purse Wade's in one way or another on
your candidate so this is like super
heavily used in politics and another may
be like a list based experiment where
you have some kind of sensitive thing
that you either have or don't have in a
list of things and then you ask them on
a question you could use this for if you
work on like a crisis team and marketing
and there's been some horrible event and
you've spilled oil all over the Gulf and
did anyone notice those kind of things
you know or they noticed but did it
actually have an effect on them buying
my product so you may want to use that's
a terrible example but you may want to
use a list list may serve experiment to
try to understand that you should
probably find a new job though so the
the crux is this attention to research
design focus is the discussion so you
now know what to talk about which is
really nice it's actually the like you
know liberating constraints idea you
don't have to talk about functional form
of the the s3n anymore it's we know very
clearly why these things go wrong
because we know how we you know our
strategy that we use to estimate things
so for instrumental variables we have
two restrictions and exclusion
restriction and irrelevance restriction
so relevance is our instrument
correlated with the endogenous variable
okay weather is correlated with price we
know that but is it an exclusion
restriction can it only affect the price
through demand or supply in this case
well yeah weather does not off the coast
does not affect whether or not someone
shows up to the farmers market or the
Fulton fish market so that's great if
you go to econ grad school this is
basically what you do for about a
hundred and fifty hours is sit in a room
and argue about whether the exclusion
restriction is met so one we can test
with stats the other we can't just brain
power this is why I call it like the
clever econometrics tricks matching the
crux of whether or not matching is valid
is basically like dude do you observe
everything that makes your pseudo
control group and your treatment group
the same or different and if you do
great you've probably created two
separate groups that are alike and
everything
but treatment if not you may have an
invalid result and we'll see a result
shows that in a second and regret
regression discontinuity the human
factor comes in
so with regression discontinuities a lot
of times people know the mechanism by
which something changes so they try to
game the system so if it's 20 you know
they'll hire a new person we're now 21
and we have a different program so that
can make those results invalid but these
are the things that we talk about this
is these are the threats to validity
that we have to check
yeah where's all the super awesome
machine learning stuff that I was told I
get to do as a data scientist so it's
still there this is kind of just the
basics and this has been kind of an area
of research and kind of an explosion
actually I don't know if I just started
paying attention to it post grad school
more for it really things really have
started to change since 2008 2010 I
think it's the latter based on the
publication date of a lot of these
papers I'm not gonna go through all of
these but just to give you a flavor so
post selection inference so scikit-learn
says I just run the lasso and it gets
rid of the variables that don't matter
and then I can just run a regression
again and then I do a t-test and we're
done right nope as soon as you ran the
lasso all statistical theory went out
the door and a lot of the work and the
post-election inference group is is
trying to figure out what that
statistical theory actually is there's
been some really cool results there and
then earlier I said you know jokingly
that a lot of these are just black box
models and it doesn't really matter and
nobody cares that's not entirely true or
fair there's been a whole lot of
research into making those things more
interpretable so if I put a record into
a basically a black box model why does
it then give me the result what part of
that record makes makes that model give
me the result that I'm getting and then
double machine learning it's pretty cool
because it does machine learning twice
now that's actually my favorite it's
like really accessible and easy to use
and kind of combines a lot of the best
of like ensemble methods with the kind
of social science techniques that we're
all well I'm used to these are
a couple of econometricians that I think
MIT and and University of Chicago okay
so now we're gonna go through just a few
case studies to like prove to you that
people are actually doing this stuff and
have actually been doing it for about
forty years once we get to the third so
shout out here is just to start or join
a journal Club of your work
Steven sitting over here runs our
journal club at work is a great way to
share ideas and continue to stay on top
of the literature and keep the team
motivated and learning new things it
takes about two or three hours a week
and it's better than what you could be
doing in that time probably and if
anybody asks tell them I said that
so the first paper I'll call kind of a
retreat to experiments so this is called
here there and everywhere correlated
online behaviors can lead to over
estimates of the effects of advertising
so this is kind of a cautionary tale
about using quasi experimental methods
in place of an experiment and this is by
Lewis and roud they were researchers at
Yahoo so they've have written a lot of
really good papers so they found that
observational experiment methods or
quasi experimental methods overestimate
the causal impact of advertising due to
what they call activity bias and we'll
talk about that in just a second but
they had three things they wanted to
look at this is this is at Yahoo the
first one was the effects of an ad on
searches so if you advertise for a
certain brand where people then
searching for things of that nature
right so they the experiment here is
they had 250 million impressions on
Yahoo and they had a 5% control group
they observed a with the experiment a
5.4 increase in search traffic via an
experiment so okay like yeah it looks
like things probably had some effect and
then they tried to replicate that
finding through quasi experimental
methods so just using matching they saw
twelve hundred percent increase in
search traffic using a regression
technique they found an eight hundred
percent increase
and search traffic these are implausible
these are why people don't think we're
credible and then
difference-in-differences they found
about a hundred percent increase in
search traffic so
difference-in-differences here like kind
of washed out a lot of the trends which
is interesting so I mean when you show
that to someone who has an intuition
about the size what the size of effect
should be or if you just like I don't
know how much how many of y'all have
actually been influenced by an ad online
to go do something probably not not most
of you then you can run into trouble if
you like come with these implausible
estimates I do think just as a caveat
like these could have been better
designed to get at the effect like you
get the twelve hundred percent and then
you refine because you know it's
implausible the second but we'll come
back to their their argument um the
second is the effective consumption on
just Yahoo pages so Yahoo used to be
like where you start on the internet so
you like you know explore around you're
not just searching which took me a
minute to remember and then so they ran
a survey experiment using Amazon
Mechanical Turk so just a way to find
survey takers they had a treatment a
control group and they wanted to show
them an ad and then see whether or not
because they measured the outcome you
know when they knew who they were
targeting did their Yahoo search
activity change so they found that it
did you know they saw it the shows in
the ad and they were searching more on
Yahoo they didn't show them the ad and
they found that they were searching more
on Yahoo so the treatment and control
here also had the same effects as
something weirds going on and then they
had a third kind of study that they
looked at these are all their
experiments and they wanted to look at
the competitive effects of advertising
so this was really interesting they got
two competitors to agree to participate
in an experiment with Yahoo so they
advertised for the competitor and then
they observed whether people signed up
or bought something from another
competitor so that called a major firm
and competitor firm so they had 200
million impressions and a ten percent
control and they tracked the signups and
the competitor and they did find the
effect so they advertised for you know
ace and then they saw the effect and
signup said true value or whatever they
also saw
then more people sign up at the firm who
was advertising so they observed both in
effect on the competitor and for the
firm that was advertising they also
observed these people just searching on
Yahoo more so they're like they're like
argument is that when people get on the
internet there's on the Internet so your
internet behavior is correlated you just
do more stuff on the internet so if you
don't have access to everything about
these people that like that advertisers
are using to target them which for the
case of you know Google Facebook or
whatever you don't then you're not going
to be able to use quasi experimental
methods to tease out the actual true
effect wolf so I think this led to a
follow up paper where they want to look
at like what are the actual limits to
measurement so they call this paper the
I think the working title was the
unfavorable economics of measuring the
returns to advertising so the conclusion
of this paper is this is very difficult
to measure whether or not ads have an
effect but it's not impossible so why is
this hard first the effect sizes are
really really small so there you know
these ad campaigns are somewhere on the
order of like five million dollars to
you know six hundred million dollars and
then the effect that they're trying to
measure is like did someone go buy
scissors at Office Depot or something so
the effect sizes are really really small
they're also really noisy so it may if
instead of buying scissors it may be
like you're buying a desk so the size of
that is very large but you do it very
infrequently so the standard deviation
to average is super super high so the
the conclusion was you should either
design an experiment it's hard you can
use observational methods but see our
earlier paper basically so just to fix
ideas about why this is hard so if the
effect sizes are small then the null
hypothesis and the alternative you know
ads have an effect is really close
together and because the standard
deviation is large these also like
really really overlap so how do you get
better estimates you have to collect a
lot of data and we call that the power
of an experiment and the power goes up
you're more likely to find
whether and if an effect exists that
it's there if you have more power so
they went and looked at 25 experiments
the experiments were across retail sales
and financial services they measured new
sales and new account signups and they
ran these experiments for two to 135
days cost up to half a million dollars
and they you know measure it anywhere
from a hundred thousand to ten million
impressions so this is the this is the
size of these studies that people had
previously undertaken and they were
going back to look at so what are the
things they wanted to look at the first
was you know okay
did there was any positive return on
advertising so I don't care how much it
costs
was there any effect and they found that
only 10 out of the 25 studies had enough
power to test any effect so okay they
did find that the ones that were powered
had a significant and positive effect so
it's not just shouting into the wind so
that's kind of nice okay but what if you
want to get a little more precise so
let's say that we have a positive return
and by positive return we mean like
wildly profitable this actually moves
the effect sizes apart and makes it
easier to measure so 50% return only
three had enough power to even make a
conclusion the median campaign would
have had to been ten times larger so if
you're running a six hundred thousand
dollar campaign you would have had to
spend six million dollars to even be
able to measure whether or not what
you're doing has an effect now say you
want to get more precise and say a 10%
return if any of us went to business
school like an IRR of 10% usually means
okay yeah we should probably undertake
this it's higher than interest rates or
whatever we could just go Park our money
somewhere
they found every single experiment was
underpowered none of the experiments
could have actually measured a 10%
return then reached it the average
retail campaign median retail campaign
would have been 60 times larger and the
financial services they would have had
to be twelve hundred times larger so
that's a pretty hefty budget just to
measure whether or not what you're
has an effect because retail super
competitive and low margins
okay that's kind of stark a a little
more positive like what are some of the
things you can do with data science used
wielded like well within an industry you
could change the course of an industry
so this has become one of my favorite
papers I recommend it to everyone and
revisit it all the time it's from the
80s and it's about Courtyard by Marriott
basically Courtyard by Marriott that we
all kind of know was designed by a bunch
of status tician consultants for
Marriott in 1983 so designing a hotel
facility with consumer based marketing
models
so basically Marriott used conjoint
analysis which is the survey experiment
that I was describing earlier about how
we can test you know what's the ideal
mix of features for a product to design
an entirely new hotel chain so they ran
a survey where they wanted to test seven
different facets each of these had 50
attributes up to eight levels so things
like should I put the pool in the middle
should the pool will be l-shaped
do people care about HBO in the rooms
you can go read the whole survey design
in the paper but they wanted to test all
of these which is an implausible thing
for any single person to have an opinion
on all of these so that's why you have
to do the survey experiment called a
conjoint analysis and what were the
actual impacts of this they also went on
to simulate okay given what we found out
via the survey experiment we're gonna
forecast the market share that you're
gonna capture and tell you actually how
many how much your profit is going to be
and they captured within 4% of the
predicted market share so that's pretty
amazing
but what was the actual impact so they
had three test cases in 83 90 and 87
predicted to be 300 by 94 with an
expected one billion dollars in sales
just from making the changes that were
prescribed by this experiment they
created 3,000 eventually 15,000 new jobs
and every single other person who was in
the kind of hospitality industry had to
change what they were doing they had to
make an offering that looked like
Courtyard by Marriott because it became
just kind of what everyone expect
so that's pretty cool just a little
stats data science so guys stay on topic
so wrapping up shout out to Judea pearl
who's keynoting later today he's made a
career talking about causal inference
and how we should be thinking about it
he was may talk about some very similar
things to what I just talked about but
using completely different language and
it should be super super entertaining so
in conclusion I think this the
credibility crisis that I've talked
about a little bit is preventable focus
on business relevant and measurable
outcomes from the start know what
success looks like I can't tell you how
often this is overlooked by people it
seems obvious but it's actually quite
difficult be clear about the causal
mechanisms that you're going to actually
test so once you have the question
understand the falsifiable hypothesis
for a research design keep it
sophisticatedly simple Arnold Zellner is
a Bayesian economy trician had this
paper called you know the kiss framework
keep it sophisticatedly simple it
doesn't have to be overly complex and
crazy but it also shouldn't be like my
numbing ly simple there's a there's a
sweet spot in there and if you hit the
sweet spot and make sure you test any of
these threats to validity and you're
honest about them then you can have a
measurable impact on the organization
when you kind of go the last mile and do
this this communication and making sure
people are taking you seriously as a
data science data scientist because you
have credibility and the I think people
get tripped up a little bit in this
testing your threats to validity because
you may be you know think okay what if I
just can't know whether or not this
thing that could make the whole house of
cards that I've just built fall down is
you know true or false save that for
later that's your next paper or your
next project right that's called
progress and it's kind of how science
has always worked and we should keep
that in mind so just because you you are
like oh I don't really know about this
assumption doesn't mean you shouldn't do
a thing or this and the thing
you're discovered is not is not valid
finally this is just like a random
smattering of papers that were on my
desk when I when I read this slide if
there's anything else like kind of
applied papers and data at the
intersection of causal inference in data
science and marketing or product or
anything feel free to sit in my way I
quite enjoy reading these I think we
have time for maybe one in question
thank you whether it's whether it's
problems with power or the application
of a quasi experiment and I think the
Chocolate changes what you're actually
estimating right this man's different
how do science respond to that and what
are your strategies to telling them
actually look we can't answer what you
hired us to do we're gonna answer this
other thing it's done so that's a really
good question it's the second time I've
been asked that is the first question
after giving this ah so you know
basically I think you're asking like is
this a hard sell to clients and like how
do you deal with it if it is so I you
know just last week we had the executive
team from a very very large financial
organization in our office and one of
the people who was with the group you
know said to me if you could just prove
me right that'd be great I have this
hypothesis I just need to know that it's
true and and frankly like it's easy for
us to make that decision we have this
kind of embedded in our company values
like we'd rather you know get fired then
not tell the truth basically so we have
had difficult conversations with some
clients about you know whether or not we
can do something for them and in the end
we've we've had to either walk away or
change their minds and sometimes we've
had you know clients where you know our
stakeholder on the other side would
leave the organization the middle of a
project and and endanger the project
because the new person is like wait what
are you doing no that sounds difficult
so it does lead to a lot of difficult
conversations one piece of advice that
I'll have and usually after that you
know the people that work you know for
with me
is to try to do two things and when
you're when you're sitting down trying
to earn the clients trust one use these
methods to show them something they
already believe and then use the methods
to show them something that they didn't
expect so then you kind of have their
trust and then it's a matter of moving
on from there yeah you mentioned you
mentioned about having the general blab
and if the company seems to be an auntie
related process how about do you have
experience having so the question about
do we have a journal Club and more in
our production company so the papers
that we read in journal club are not
just social science methodology paper
like we read the Google span or paper we
read the data flow paper so we're also
reading about what's going on and you
know modern distributed databases and
you know modern data engineering those
kind of things
we just started reading a couple of
books about user centered design so we
have a few different book clubs not just
like the more academic journal Club that
we have so we have a management book
club we have design book club so like
human-computer interaction user centered
design those kind of things generally if
you know it's part of someone's job
they're going to be interested in
getting better at it and you always
learn when you sit down and read and
have conversations about it
[Applause]